dans trois jours c'est quoi c'est l'été
l'été sera chaud l'été sera chaud dans
les tee shirts
alors on connaît déjà les tubes qui vont
cartonner cet été je vous le dis alors
clairement il ya trois grosses tendances
qui se dégagent sertic toc c'est wade n
très moche et black & decker et bien sûr
il ya mont canisy et oui je sais pas
pourquoi je sens que je vois kenji
bientôt son jeu sans kaka ni je vais le
voir bientôt s'éteindre et vous quel est
le tube de l'été
allez on récapitule tout ça bien entendu
c'est parti
vous diriez le garder
si on a longtemps pensé qu'il serait
difficile de danser cet été avec le
déconfinement qui s'accélère et les
projets de vacances qui se dessine se
pose maintenant une question essentielle
mais quel sera le tube de l'été car le
confinement n'a visiblement pas
totalement arrêté l'industrie musicale
dont certains artistes sont déjà en
bonne place pour nous faire danser dans
les mois à venir
c'est le cas par exemple de webzen qui
avec sa chanson anissa est devenu en
quelques semaines un véritable phénomène
[Musique]
son côté ken chirac revient fort lui
aussi avec son titre habib sy écrit par
slimane un single qui avec ses rythmes
orientaux a déjà conquis le coeur de
nombreux auditeurs
côté bosch opéré dans validé avec son
job se classe cette semaine en première
place du top singles a toutes ses
chances d'être lui aussi sacré tube de
l'été
alors quel sera le grand gagnant réponse
dans les semaines à venir
[Musique]
alors vous savez que wade n est déjà à
11 me mais je sais wen j'adore j'adore
norme est alors moi demain je suis pas
pro champ que y'a kenji qu'ils voteront
aussi une ravissante et rapide il va pas
chanter à dalhousie
oui demain dans la poêle qui est passé
non mais tu me trompé je le sens je sais
pas pourquoi c'est fou ça comment se
sent on va jouer avec angie demain je le
sens alors quelle est votre préférée
vous d'étroits pourparlers
c'est kenjy et bosh et vestel mais clin
d'oeil à fait d'accord camille abboche
d'accord j'aime bien mais fait un
classement un deux trois ans alors quoi
aller mais non mais écoutez imagine
alors pas là pour faire des questions
des annonceurs vous avez un tendon
récent mais pas du tout mais je me
change et les pas honnête vous ne
demandez à nous de trancher vous
tranchez pas un événement vous je serais
toi tu le paieras ne veulent pas de me
bernard montiel invente un peu non comme
maya nakamura
ouais c'est ça un petit hors de ma vie
c'est un neuf langues mais franchement
les jeunes ils adorent et ça cartonne et
parodies sur tik tok a là des centaines
de milliers m'acheter mes filles elles
sont complètement dingue avec ses
parodies et si l'on veut mais on adore
il a su ce qu'elle raconte une histoire
dans sa chasse on sait que c'est une
petite amie l'a trompée avec sa cousine
ce qu'on sait c'est l'histoire voilà
elle a jeté sa sur le papier mois les
cousines ça devient terrible ah ben oui
thierry perin scission avec des résines
moi je veux même plus voir les cousines
peut plus voir personne je ne veux plus
voir personne
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus de règle en
amour